if there's an up-and-coming artist who's
watching this who might have a little
something going on and labels
always trying to sign you
there's majors there's many majors
there's you know it's just
distribution whatever right
would you suggest someone go the major
label route right now i mean well this
depends on what they want in the
beginning right i as an artist i wanted
to be played on the radio i wanted to be
signed to a major because it's just this
grandiose thing about doing music
if they feel that the deal is structured
in a way that they can still get the joy
of being signed and it be fair then by
all means do it my personal experience
might not be like someone else's i know
a lot of artists at our side and they
seem to get a fair shake in it they get
the check they get the support they do
the late night shows and it seems to
work it didn't necessarily work for me
right and so i can't expect somebody to
take my
role with it because this isn't easy you
know it's definitely a role less
traveled you it's like being it's like
being on a private airport i talk about
all this time it's like when you with a
label it's a huge airport and there's
planes leaving you're at lax you know
going independent you're at burbank you
get to walk right through yeah but
when it's when when the air is full you
can't take off this is true and you
and it's harder to get to some
destinations there's connecting flights
you gotta you gotta connect yeah so and
for me it's like once we figured it out
but it was so weird once we left def jam
and we told people that i was leaving it
was so many [ __ ] they're like
where are you you signing downtown yeah
i don't think a lot of people knew that
who weren't just like
to the song like he was like yeah i was
with them
for six seven years
it was a minute and as it's like oh we
didn't even [ __ ] know it's like
it's so crazy it's it's crazy too
because like i think of like
i just don't know i don't know man as a
fan i just was like what the [ __ ] is def
jam doing like none like anything you'd
like feature wise or like
all that [ __ ] it was we there was some
still some great people we we met there
and then even with me it was the
understanding that i'm from the south
i'm from a place that a lot of people
haven't even been right so when you talk
about trying to create a certain kind of
um what's the word i want to use support
in a building where they seeing their
favorite artists come through all the
time right and it was a lot of young
people and yeah they might [ __ ] with me
as a person but they weren't might not
been into my music might not have knew
about my music they want to promote for
their favorite artists right
and so you know you run into that man
you get to the situation where you the
album come out you go in the office and
everybody in the building playing your
songs and you like i know good and damn
well y'all don't do this every day
and so when you appreciate them trying
yeah but we went out and we was we knew
that i had um hard ticket sales that i
had support from people because i was on
the ground and we was doing all the runs
meeting the djs and i'm very hands-on
with how i interact with people and so
that helped my career tremendously bro
that it didn't matter that we didn't
have certain
outlets and certain press and push
because we still were selling our shows